there's some encouraging news in the
race to find a coronavirus vaccine a new
study
study from oxford university says its
experimental vaccine
prompted an immune response in hundreds
who received the shot
a key sign of progress charlie dagetta
spoke to the scientist leading the
trials
america's one billion dollar bet on the
oxford vaccine just got a lot closer to
paying off
professor sarah gilbert what's the most
important takeaway from what we've
learned today
that the vaccine is safe and it's giving
us strong immune responses and it should
go into further clinical trials
the strong immune response they'd hoped
for the deployment of antibodies
and crucial killer t cells antibodies
detect a virus and neutralize it
t cells are more like assassins not only
attacking
infected human cells but retaining a
memory of the virus ready to mount a
defense
the next time the same pathogen tries to
invade
what are the biggest challenges left now
that phase one
and phase two are complete or underway
what's what's next
looking at the performance of the
vaccine in older people is really
important
we know that most vaccines don't give
such strong immune responses as the
immune system
ages the trump administration has put
1.2 billion dollars on the line
for drug giant astrazeneca to produce at
least 300 million doses as soon as
they're ready to go
in an online briefing astrazeneca ceo
pascal sorio says
they're on track our hope is that
we can actually start delivering a
vaccine
by before the end of the year professor
gilbert
is a bit more measured pascal sorrio
said this afternoon he's still hoping
for like october november
well we all have hopes there are no
guarantees
i mean i don't want to put a date on it
because it's just impossible to tell
we're working as hard as we can to do
everything we need to do as fast as we
can
and we'll get the result when we get the
result
in fact things are moving much faster
than at any time
in history from identifying a pathogen
to getting this
close to developing a workable vaccine
work here started back in january in
what they call their
little lab here at oxford university now
the entire world is watching and waiting
tony so far so good charlie thank you
very much